in this video we'll be going through the
story of muzan kibbutsuji the progenitor
backstory when muzan was in his mother's
womb his heart stopped multiple times he
was said to have been stillborn having
no pulse and not breathing however when
he was taken to be cremated he released
his first cries as a young man muzan was
diagnosed with a disease that would kill
him before he reached the age of 20. the
doctor treating muzan gave him a special
prototype medicine enraged by his
worsening condition muzan killed him
only after killing the doctor did he
realize that the medicine was actually
working and helped him acquire a strong
body he realized he needed to consume
the flesh of humans to survive but was
not bothered by this fact his new more
serious problem on the other was his
inability to walk in the sunlight as
doing so burned him severely it was
during this moment that he truly
regretted killing the doctor before he
could have finished his treatment with
his blue spider lily medicine he
searched the entire country for the
flower but couldn't find it due to this
muzan started to create more demons and
planned to spread them in the world
hoping that one of them would eventually
find a way to overcome the sun or at
least help him in his quest to find the
blue spider lily this desire to be in
the sun again became his one true goal
and he spends hundreds of years chasing
this obsession before we continue with
muzan's story we want to thank raid
shadow legends for sponsoring this video
imagine over 600 different champions all
from unique factions and with their own
stories fighting fearlessly in the
mythical land tilleria well you don't
have to imagine anymore use my links
below to download raid yourself to your
phone or pc this month raid just brought
the latest addition to its huge boss
roster and it's raid's biggest and
scariest yet the hydra this thing is the
ultimate beast it's got multiple
different heads and each one has unique
characteristics to be honest with you
i'm still trying to figure out how to
take this thing down but i'll manage
eventually currently my favorite
champion is this guy named kale he has
this amazing ability called acid rain
that lets me damage all my opponents
simultaneously i really like the way all
the champions are designed even the most
basic champions looks so cool raid's
also giving away a super limited edition
champion to every player in the game
some of you may recognize him already
it's counter-strike legend and superstar
simple all you have to do is log in for
seven days between now and january 28th
and he's yours this is the best time to
get started in raid and if you use my
link in the description or scan my qr
code you'll get a free mystery champion
straight away to kickstart your game
thank you raid for supporting the
channel and let's get back to the video
around to the oei era muzan found a
young girl named tameo who was afflicted
with a disease that threatened her life
she encounters muzan and wishing to see
her children grow up allowed him to
transform her unused to her new body she
inadvertently killed her own family to
survive as well as another group of
people this decision haunted her to no
end and she became resentful and hateful
of muzan but due to muzan's immense
power she was unable to kill him with
success muzon enslaved tamiyo and she
followed him around as a lowly servant
some time after he finds michikatsu suki
kuni a marked demon slayer and user of
the moon breathing style michikatsu
wanted to become more powerful than his
brother and loved the fact that his
status of being marked meant his life
would soon end muzan issued a compromise
he wished to have a breath using demon
and in return he could live forever and
perfect his skill michikatsu agreed and
muzan gave him an extremely high
concentration of his blood emerging
three days later transformed and taking
the name of kokoshibo later muzan and
tamiya would encounter a demon slayer
named yurichi suki kuni the moment the
two met yurichi sensed muzan's malice
into anger comparing him to boiling
magma simultaneously muzan found nothing
in yurichi that resembled something
dangerous and didn't fear his opponent
already satisfied having kokushibo as a
subordinate muzan tried to kill yuriji
without warning he however was able to
dodge the blows and discerned himself's
weak spots seven hearts and five brains
that moved freely around his body urich
combined all his forms into one strike
and turned his blade bright red enabling
him to crush through all of muzon's
weaknesses and to overpower him for the
first time in his life muzan became
stunned unable to heal he sat in the
pool of his blood and stared angrily at
yurichi ignoring his question on what he
thought was the value of a life when
yurichi moved forward to kill him muzan
used the remains of whatever power he
had left and divided his body in a
powerful burst though yurichi was able
to destroy nearly all the fragments the
pieces he missed escaped and allowed
mizon to regenerate again muzan was
deeply scarred by this encounter and
with kokoshibo's assistance the two
slaughtered anyone who used sun
breathing in the hopes of preventing
another demon slayer that had the power
to kill him greatly fearful of the man
he considered the real demon muzan never
directly confronted the demon slayers
again and sent demons to do his bidding
for the most part muzan hears news of a
massacre involving the violent deaths of
67 people he traveled to the village
before meeting the culprit an 18 year
old boy named takuji he voiced his
disappointment as he believed a demon
had committed the act instead of a human
hakuji threatened him but was silenced
by muzan piercing his hand through his
head the demon king spoke of his plan to
form a faction of 12 powerful demons and
asked the young man if he was able to
withstand the amount of blood he was
given hakuji broken by his lost and with
nothing else left didn't resist and
became the demon akuza in time muzani
eventually succeeded in creating his
faction which would eventually become
known as the 12 kazuki he transformed
multiple demons and gave them a chance
to join his group rewarding them with a
larger share of his blood to make them
more powerful during the taisho era
muzan was able to locate the commodo
family who were keepers of the sun
breathing technique when tantra again
was away at town muzon attacked his
family and proceeded to inject them with
his blood hopeful that he could create a
demon who could withstand the sun
however he was disappointed when the
family died from his blood's poison
believing that creating a sun proof
demon was not so easy after all he left
their home seemingly unaware that there
was a survivor nezuko comodo who later
turned into a demon asakusa arc
traveling through the crowd in osakusa
tokyo with his family muzan is accosted
by an angry tanjiro muzan's daughter
asked him who the young demon slayer was
and he asked the youth if there was
something he wanted from him his wife
then approached them asking if tanjura
was somebody familiar to their family
muzan denies this suggesting the boy had
mistaken them for somebody else then he
quickly slashes a passing man turning
him into a demon during the commotion he
and his family leave while tanjo is
forced to tend to the demonified man
afterwards muzan sends his family home
in a carriage without him declaring he
had some work to do he wanders through
an alley where a drunk man bumps into
him the man mocks and insults him saying
he doesn't like wealthy people like him
when the drunk man notes how pale his
skin is muzan slashes him into a wall
and proceeds to kill the man's older
brother with a swift upwards kick he
then turns to the drunk man's cowering
girlfriend and asks if he looks pale or
close to death muzan answers his own
questions and tells her how he is
infinitely close to perfection he then
drills his finger into her forehead
pumping her with so much blood that her
cells melt afterwards he calls susamaru
and yahuba and orders them to kill
tonjiro rehabilitation training arc the
lower ranks have a meeting where muzan
appears in the form of a woman he is
very disappointed after rui's defeat so
much so that he declares he will disband
the lower ranks and that he will now
only lead the upper ranks he kills
kamanohe after reading his mind when he
thought disrespectful thoughts and
tomoko for contradicting him as wakaraba
tries to escape muzan decapitates him
and renders him unable to regenerate
rokuro tries to plead with his master
and asks for more of his blood to prove
himself seeing the demon as a failure
muzan becomes incredibly angry and kills
him for ordering his leader before
killing enmu the demon states how much
he enjoyed making humans suffer and
thanks rizan for letting him be his
final victim seeing potential in enmu
muzon gives him a high abundance of
blood enmu almost dies from the new load
of power but manages to survive muzon
then gives him one last chance to prove
that the lower ranks are not useless
moog and train arc muzon leads another
life among humans as a small boy named
toshikuni and pretends to have a skin
condition which prevents him from
stepping into the sun after killing
kyojiro and goku akisa reports to muzon
and tells him of his victory however
muzan is not pleased enough by the death
of the hashira and instead shows anger
that akasa let all the other present
demon slayers get away additionally
berating him for not finding more
information on the blue spider lily
entertainment district arc in the red
light district wuzan talks to daki he
tells her how proud of her he is and
that he hopes she'll become even crueler
and stronger he also lets you know about
nezuko and leaves it to her to kill her
after the fight he orders the upper
ranks to meet at the infinity castle he
is standing on the ceiling and
experimenting trying to heal his sun
weakness muzan tells them that he won't
allow any failures such as daki and
gyotaro muzan regrets putting so much
confidence in her and wishes gyotaro had
fought since the beginning he tells them
to serve him with a more suicidal
devotion and states how he hates change
he believes change only means decline
and he didn't change for so long since
he is practically perfect he then sent
gyoko and huntengu to destroy the
swordsmith village before departing from
the meeting sword smith village arc
muzan feels through hantengu that nezuko
was indeed able to become a demon who
overcame the sun thus making his assault
on the sun breathing family a success he
was in the disguise of a small boy when
he hears this his foster mom and maid
come in but muzan instantly kills them
he is extremely excited and sets his
mind on getting nezuko hashira training
arc he appoints nakime as upper rank 4
and makes her more powerful he uses her
to scout the whereabouts of all demon
slayers he is quite impressed by her
efforts and compliments her he says that
he is sure to soon find neziko and
kagaya infinity castle arc muzan appears
in the uyashiki mansion and sees kagaya
he mocks him for his weak appearance
kagaya tries to lecture musan and points
out how the hashira will never give up
trying to kill him muzan laughs and
proceeds to attack kagaya before he can
kill him however the mansion explodes
with muzon cottonette the explosion
which was enhanced by spike traps
manages to injure muzan before he is
able to regenerate fully tomio appears
and uses her blood demon art to keep him
in place while using a drug that can
turn him into a human using this
opportunity gyomehimejima appears and
destroys muzon's head however he is able
to instantly regrow his head as all of
the other hashira join the fight the
infinity castle appears as if sucking in
all people nearby and scattering them
buzan claims he will slaughter them all
tonight as the demon slayers manage to
beat the majority of the upper ranks and
attempt to locate muzan several lower
ranked members are able to find his
cocoon emerging from it he proceeds to
eviscerate all the demon slayers in his
proximity as he tries to regain the
stamina lost from his struggle against
damio he takes her head and mocks her
for being unable to kill him ridiculing
that the drug she designed was useless
tomio angrily demands that mizon return
her family to her to which muzan replies
that she should join them on the other
side and crushes her head he further
proceeds to slaughter demon slayers and
to reaffirms his vow to kill all of them
through nakime's ability muzanas plays
face to face with tanjuro and giu muzan
askedandro why he's so concerned with
revenge against him when he got out of
the massacre of his family alive and
thus can resume his life if he wanted to
comparing himself to a great calamity he
states that it is impossible for humans
to take revenge on natural disasters
like rain winds volcanic eruptions or
earthquakes that take lives of dear ones
humans keep on living and that fighting
him amounts to the same kind of folly he
thus concludes that the demon slayers
fight him because they are a group of
deviants and that he is tired of dealing
with them and is the only one who wants
to truly put an end to the fight in
enraged tangero claims muzan should not
have been allowed to exist a battle
ensues with buzan extending his arms
into long bladed whips keeping guillo
and tanjuro at bay tantro navigates
between wizan's strikes and attempts at
infiltrating but is ultimately
unsuccessful in slash near his eye giu
pulls tandro away reminding the latter
that muzan's power is above any of the
upper demons buzan wonders if they can
defeat him with just three hashira and
declares that mitsuri and obanai were
killed by nakime muzan performs more
sweeps that tanjore can hardly avoid due
to his injured eye as he stumbles before
he can kill tanjuro mitsuri appears
smashing the walls and attacking muzan
with her love breathing but is unable to
inflict any damage on buzan much to her
frustration open eye also appears
revealing both ashira to be alive an
angered muzan demands his explanations
from nakime only to learn that yushiro
had used his own blood demon art to take
control of nakime and that he will force
muzan out of the infinity castle further
angered by the opposition muzon tries to
wrestle control of the castle back from
yushiro as he tries to absorb his cells
through nakime an attack from geyu and
obani force muzon in the defensive
allowing yushiro to win control so muzon
remotely detonates nakime crushing her
head while her remaining cells are still
alive yushiro uses them to take control
of the castle as it continuously shifts
before mizon can land a critical blow on
mitsuri tantra throws a broken nature
and blade which stabs himself in the
head causing him to miss he grows
furious with tanjiro as the castle
breaks into the surface sunrise
countdown arc now out of city the demon
slayers are told to stall muzon for one
more hour and a half until sunrise a
furious muzan now with whips from his
spine emerges from debris and dares them
to try wildly swinging his limbs the
hashera sees a chance to slash him but
to their surprise he regenerates so fast
that he cannot be decapitated before he
can fatally wound them hordes of lesser
ranked demon slayers push the hashira
out of harm's way ready to die is human
shields as muzan murders dozens of them
he muses that they were fortunate to die
immediately and points to tanjuro as an
example of the contrary showing a
horrible facial burn muzan reveals he
injected blood into tonjiro on his
earlier attack and that his body will be
destroyed boasting that he is already
dead muzan in the hashira exchange blows
and notices that the demon slayers with
their mark activated can resist the
effect of his demonic blood as muzan
tries to land a killing blow in midziri
gyome saves her sonomy takes the chance
to slash muzan from behind who reacts to
the hashira's attack sonomy tosses vials
filled with flammable liquid and
proceeds to set muzon ablaze as the
battle rages on the hashera have
difficulty in fighting muzan who proves
to be too powerful for them an exhausted
mitsuri who does nothing but evade is
ultimately injured and forced out of the
fight despite her desire to battle
obanai takes notice and tries to fight
harder against muzan trying to slice and
kick his severed member away to delay
his regeneration but only making a
minimal difference remembering his own
past he decides to fight for her sake
and die to meet her in another life gil
loses the ability to hold his nietzsche
in blade with only a little more than 15
minutes passing when all seems lost
joshua maru tamio's cat servant appears
and throws syringes at the shira dosing
them with the serum that counteracts
muzon's poison muzon kills the cat and
grows annoyed hotamio still gets in his
way even after death obani thinks
hamuito may have managed to get his
blade to turn red and puts all his focus
and effort into his grip turning it red
however he starts to lose consciousness
due to lack of oxygen obani is sent
mid-air and miraculously manages to
avoid muzan's attack as muzan's right
arm and spinal whips are sliced muzan is
left wondering how it happens and
realizes it is impossible for any of the
hashera to have been able to cut him he
is then sliced in his left arm which
makes him take notice the uneven cut he
has in his arm muzon correctly deduces
that somebody is attacking him while
hidden through yushiro's technique
feeling the air around imparting he
narrows the location of his three
attackers being none other than enosuke
zenitsu and kaneo whom he manages to
barely slash opennight takes the chance
to slice muzon's arms which regenerates
slower due to his red blade zenitsu and
ganio turn invisible again and attack
muzon in unison causing the demon lord
to complain an irritation at their small
tricks guillemet is glad to have more
support as he is able to clash his axe
and iron ball to heat them through
friction increasing their attack power
gyome soon slashes the left side of
muzon's torso sonomy and giu follow suit
and clash their blades turning them red
the kasugai crow wins that one hour and
three minutes remain before dawn with
the demon slayers regaining advantage
suddenly muzon performs an undisclosed
technique allowing him to defeat all his
attackers simultaneously injuring and
having them crash on nearby buildings
mutilating giome's left leg and gives
right arm in the process kaneo tsuyuri
is left with a broken blade kneeling in
shock before muzon can kill her a
recovered tanjore saves her slicing
busan's arm leaving him shocked seeing
tantra's mutated face as a result of his
poison muzan comments that he looks
terrible and wonders now who is the true
demon between the two of them seeing
yurichi's image in tanjuro muzan feels
disgust at the demon slayer while tanjro
states that it's time they finish things
their battle begins with tanjo
remembering the forms of the sun
breathing he witnessed during his dream
he comes to realize that the forms must
be employed consecutively one after the
other which will lead to the 13th and
strongest form though he feels
discouraged and not having eurychi's or
his father's skill tantra nevertheless
ventures to attack muzon who sees the
ghost of his former enemy on the younger
demon slayer turning his blade red
chandra begins to unleash the sun
breathing forms trying to become
stronger in the brink of death muzan is
unimpressed as tanjo's technique is far
from urichi's level seeing him losing
strength as he tries to secure the
chance to entendro once and for all who
is weakening from exhaustion and his own
injuries muzan however is unable to land
a finishing blow much to his own
surprise and realizes he too is growing
weaker he deduces that it must be
tamio's doing as he had absorbed her
cells and tries to communicate with her
essence in the cells to ask what the
drug she injected him with was truly
about tomio's essence merely mocks him
much to mazzan's irritation who proceeds
to destroy what remains of her
consciousness and scan her memories
instead witnessing her memories he comes
to learn the truth that tamiya yushiro
and shinobu gocho did indeed develop a
drug that turned demons into humans but
added an additional poison with a
powerful aging effect making uzan age at
a rate of 50 years per minute muzan
realizes that his body has weakened as
it is struggling to keep his body
youthful he begins calculating the time
the drug has been active for roughly
three hours meaning he has aged 9 000
years tantro keeps unleashing successive
forms of the sun breathing irritating
the demon lord with his persistence with
59 minutes left before dawn tantra was
able to connect all 12 forms and
resolves himself to reuse them all
faster than before muzan continues to
lash at tanjuro who is slowly being
overcome with oxygen deprivation and
losing his footing but is saved by
obanai who is restored to health by
yushiro and who is revealed to have lost
his sight during wazon's earlier use of
his leg tentacles the two split as busan
chases after obani and obliterates a
building trying to kill him but fails as
muzangro is weaker from the aging venom
and the efforts of the demon slayers
scars become visible across all of
muzon's body tangible realizes that
those are the wounds inflicted by urichi
burned down to a cellular level which
never healed despite hundreds of years
and which reveal his weak points muzon
grows horrified at the sight of his
wounds thinking that yorichi a mere man
who displayed no apparent hostility was
in fact the true monster between the two
of them by crippling him the way he did
tanjuro and obani continue their assault
on muzan now with 40 minutes left before
dawn muzan grows relentless and tries to
escape trampling over the corpses of the
demon's slayers he slaughtered this
enrages tandro who proceeds to throw
multiple neutron blades at muzan who
deflects them reasoning that stabs are
much worse than slashes now obanise
stabs muzon in the neck from behind
making the ladder uses spinal whips
which are stopped by tanjiro who tries
to give obani a pair of euchiro's
blindfold so he can share khabiromaru's
vision although muzan wounds the two of
them to block their efforts kaburamaru
succeeds in fetching the papers allowing
obanite to fight in much better
condition muzon slowly succumbs to panic
as he is running out of breath as the
strength is reaching critical lows muzan
is further pressured by the attacks of
tanjuro and obani and with 35 minutes
before dawn muzan deems an unnecessary
risk to continuing to fight and attempts
to divide himself into lumps escaping in
the same manner he did against yuriji
tanjuro alerts obani of this and panics
at the idea that the two of them won't
be able to destroy all the flesh lumps
however muzan is unable to split as a
third drug injected by tomio has the
property to slow down cell division
muzon communicates with the essence of
tamiyo who gleefully alerts him that
there are not three effects but four
with the fourth drug causing goes on to
cough blood as it triggers cell
destruction after the third effect
activated the essence of tomio taunts
muzom that the death he so much feared
is coming for him further elaborating
that she doesn't need to be stronger
than him to kill him as weakening him
suffices muzan ponders that normally the
attacks used by the demon slayers
shouldn't be threatening nor should
prolonged regeneration prove tiring but
tomio's drugs have turned otherwise
manageable attacks into lethal threats
and that he is unable to fully get
accustomed to the toxins in his body
which are much different than those used
to kill doma in a desperate attempt to
live busan opens a gaping mouth in his
chest and unleashes a potent discharge
against obanai and tanjuro with just 25
minutes before dawn the weakened kirya
who witnesses the fight from afar begs
for someone to stall muzan his pleas are
answered when hinosuke attacks buzan
lunging at the demon lord furious for
the previous thrashing into mourning the
comrades muzan is killed and injured
muzan unable to further use his previous
technique resorts to lunging his arm
into the ground wrapping an escape with
his tentacle inosuke is saved by the
timely intervention of zennitoo who
tells a nosekate that tantro is still
alive begging the latter to stay alive
for the sake of nezuko muzan swings his
arm at zhenitsu crashing him into a
building but is saved by enosuke who
stabs his arm only to be swapped away by
another swing in the process muzon is
under heavy fatigue and irritated as the
boys continue to stand up to fight him
inosuke and zenitsu continue their
assault on muzan with the latter using
his thunder breathing seventh form hinoi
kazuchi no kami managing to slash muzan
but the attack was more shallow than
expected anosuke keeps attacking buzan
with his techniques forcing the demon
lord to employ his shockwave once more
before he can attack enosuke tangible
recovers and unleashes successive
sun-breathing techniques tangera weakens
after using hinokami kagura giving muzon
an opening but has his tentacles sliced
by a noseguy busan swathes enosuke away
into a building and tanjuro loses
footing but zenitu manages to recover
enough to use one last attack but is
himself injured by muzon tantro seizes
the chance and stabs muzon pinning him
to a building unable to use any more
techniques as he gambles at all and
keeping luzon in place muzan tries to
kill tanjiro but a recovered kinroji
entangles herself to his tentacles while
ripping off his left arm walmazan's
right arm and tentacles are sliced by
sonomy left with little choice a
bifurcation appears in buzan's front
revealing an enormous bestial mouth
trying to eat tanjuro who cannot do
anything but remain in place to protect
him obernite puts himself in harm's way
as he is mauled by muzan as dawn is
breaking muzon panics at the side of the
sun and desperately unleashes a powerful
shock wave catapulting his attackers
away except for tanjuro who loses his
left arm but firmly stays in place
trying to turn his blade red the blade
changes injuring muzon in response to
the sun's menace uzon proceeds to
enlarge in himself adopting a large
demonic baby form absorbing tonjiro in
the process as muzan tries to get into
shade hordes of demon slayers block his
path by tossing bookshelves and ramming
vehicles on him as he fights back for a
way through he is soon blocked by
another group of demon slayers pushing a
bus on him to prevent his escape muzon
soon begins burning from the sun forcing
him to fight for his life before he can
overwhelm the lower ranked slayers
sonomy appears and slices his right arm
as he tries to climb over the bus
blockade he has a chain tied to his neck
by guillaume aided by multiple slayers
who pull together to bring muzon down as
he burns further muzan resorts to
digging as an escape maneuver forcing
guil sonomy and obanite to attack him to
deplete his stamina soon the chains
break in what appears to be a hopeless
moment but tanjiro who remains within
muzan is able to ignite his blade and
enter him from the inside causing buzan
to flinch from the pain as he begins
disintegrating from the sun's light as
his body fully burns to ash the once
invincible demon lord who ruled the
shadows of japan spreading misery and
suffering for millennia finally laid in
defeat ending the seemingly eternal war
with the demon slayer's victory thank
you guys so much for watching this video
it really means a lot to us
we will see you guys very soon in one of
our next videos